Peters getting a lot of love what do you
think about the fan left for Peter I
mean I'm not surprised Peters getting
love Peter's very handsome I mean all my
talk four guys are handsome let's just
be you like some good ones I think you
did but I'm not surprised of that no bad
Peters a likable guy
Peter's high school yearbook photo came
out and in it he said one day he wanted
to be on The Bachelor didn't seem that
surprised you it did I mean I saw it I
thought okay well I guess dreams come
true I mean you're on you're on The
Bachelorette close enough good for you
Peter
I mean I can't judge him for what he
wrote at 18 I mean I wouldn't want
anybody to judge me for the things that
I was doing at 18 so totally
hypothetical we do not know who you end
up with but would Peter make a good
bachelor since that was his high school
dream it's so hard for me to say that
because I feel slightly possessive over
the men that were on my season you know
do I think he's a great person he's
obviously handsome absolutely
so what he sure all my top four would
but I don't want to see any of them at
the next batch do you still feel a
little bit like mmm mine yeah
let's pick someone from Joe Joe season
for me it would be an honor to come to
your hometown I cannot wait to take it
home to my family friends after
hometowns moving forward what are your
biggest fears about Peter well with
Peter it's pretty obvious what his mom
talked about is he ready does he want
the same things that I want I didn't
come here for a boyfriend I came here
for someone who wanted to propose who
hopefully could find that in me and you
know we want the same things with each
other that's my biggest concern with
Peter and is he ready
you